going to play a game right now you've
heard of hot or not but this is going to
be
bang or
not we're going to think of a different
word we couldn't think of a different
word so let's just picture is going to
be thomas just and giselle real quick
lebron
bang or not he's married so i would
never even consider it so if let's say
he wasn't let's say he got a
relationship with you for six months
yeah that's low
that's [ __ ] up are you gonna
contribute to cartier
that was traumatic donation
well let's go through this because we do
want to get to our rapid fire round so
let's just scroll down we got 10 names
that we want to get to i don't mess with
anybody it's married okay gotcha
well let's just pretend they're not
married okay they're all single
okay david oh sorry number one is tom
brady can can i have her too like i want
the two-pack yes boom double pack
tom brady giselle go for it number two
david beckham i mean yeah him and his
wife as well two-pack two-pack bang
a-rod hell [ __ ] no wow no a-rod why
no a-rod
because he's just he's he's just a pain
in the ass he's an annoying person i'm
so glad they broke up i'm so glad she's
living her best life and he's just still
single
um he's just fake he's just annoying and
he's actually part of the reason why
dudes do better my new podcast was an
inception it was on the same time as
watch cartier guy
they broke up and he was texting me
asking me to introduce him to a girl
that i know with all of these
qualifications like i'm some [ __ ]
dating service like i've got time
to be like can you a tall intelligent
nice woman like oh my god no you lost
get out of here so a rod you're done so
whatever so
by the way are you more into guys than
women or women again we're into guys but
if it's a pairing you know like like the
brady's or whatever i mean yeah you know
you just get tom brady on the phone yeah
okay next who's next
next we got steph curry
i just i'm so
i love his family so much and his wife
do these cooking things i can't even get
past it so i'm going to say no no sorry
steph you got a great shot but no shot
with lee singh that three-point shot he
has andy roddick
married to a supermodel he is and
they're both beautiful so i'm taking
them both
let's go bang bang we got cristiano
ronaldo oh yeah i mean hello yes yes
also his girlfriend's really hot if you
had a type i would renovate your type do
you have a specific type i have not yet
figured out my type
they're all this time
look i've only been married once yes i
the six-month relationship is the only
exclusive relationship outside of my
marriage i've had i had a 10-year thing
going on that was just like an open
relationship where we weren't exclusive
but
that just got all like i just don't and
they're all and they would all be
arranged very differently so i don't
know
yet
if you'd like to but yes i mean i feel
like you're a lot of people polyamorous
or are they just physical we um physical
we it was like a good friendship where
you hook up as well but you don't ask
each other what you're doing on the off
time but you will like do things like
test before you see each other otherwise
there's a condom involved like i'm real
i'm a stickler with that like hey if
you're gonna do your own thing that's
cool but if we're gonna have a weekend
together on vacation let's both go get
an std test and then we can have sex
with a condom if not let's lisa do you
have any idea i was on a podcast so were
you fresh and fit and they asked every
girl what's your body count that's
disgusting pretty graphic question man
oh someone asked adele that on a live
and she didn't know what it meant and
she saw that that broke my heart for her
how could you ask adele that
do you know what i mean
because she thought it was like a fat
thing probably yeah and you know what i
thought i see things happen on social
media that just i break inside because
i've taken all this abuse right because
you're a porn star the whole world
abuses you so you just you but you don't
want it for other people right like i'd
rather somebody say that to me than a
doubt so take one for adele what do you
have an idea of what what your name is
do not okay it's probably two or three
or you know maybe more but when people
ask i say between three and five
thousand because there was an era of
ecstasy where there was a lot of group
sex but it's highly exaggerated but it's
just to be funny it's funny you do have
a sense of humor cristiano ronaldo
everyone's gonna bang that yeah
uh russell wilson and sierra
yeah cause i'm taking both of them i
mean she's way hotter yeah
but look at him going to the commanders
i don't know how i feel about that that
stadium is a [ __ ] show
that's the new washington post
that's
number eight we have
you know what i i'm not very familiar
with him but i'm doing him because he's
italian i know she's a great
center now italians they're known for
not sniffing the tip do you have any
thoughts on that i don't mind that at
all okay hooded knights yeah it doesn't
bother me either way i'll take it mm-hmm
no no no
amber's jewish i don't like that at all
when you go to europe to shoot in the
industry you really face it like quickly
you start you realize like oh this is an
american thing and then i'll tell you
there's a different level of
satisfaction as a woman because you do
get to see it grow more
so there's there's a factor of there
like you know it's not just there it's
like you've got to do a little bit of
work surprise yeah number nine
yeah yeah a little more work now we got
the rock the wayne the guy married by
the way not me
who wouldn't the rock he's a monster do
you think that guy's packing i don't you
know usually bigger
or not i'm with her you think bigger
guys are not especially if you've done
any sort of voids or anything like that
also
the backdrop is so big right the
backdrop is so big that it's gonna look
smaller hey listen i got something for
him if you'd like to get some landscape
for a little bit bigger
wow
dave so what about little guy do you
think little guys are you know
you know what sometimes with a dick on a
stick you're not expecting
10 final person on this list
is carrot top the the uh not carrot top
sorry you know what i'm going to tell
you sean white don't do that the flying
carrot i apologize not sean white he
just retired i'm gonna pass i too i
should say no to at least we're not into
ginger
you're not into gingers it's i'm not
judging the ginger thing he's just not
my type okay who's not on this list that
you said you forgot about blank and i'd
love to blank blank
man i used to look at dwight howard's
arms at the free throw line and just be
like this is masturbation material those
the glistening of his skin as well his
shoulders he would just be like please
do i would be like please dribble just a
couple more you know just you should
have triple clicked
so good though yeah he also can't really
make a free throw but yeah he also has a
very beautiful smile yeah that's a smile
so dwight howard that's your guy if you
could it's not really my guy but i mean
like i do think he's got like nine kids
from eight baby moms easily i'm sure and
he can't remember all the names like
antonio cromartie remember he was asked
i'm like yeah i got uh antonio jr and
antonio
he was on an interview for like hard
knocks or something and they started
asking he could not remember the name of
all of his children okay so so speaking
of nba guys this is a perfect segue
uh there's an nba players though look at
that you would touch them don't you want
to touch them
[Laughter]
so that is bang or not featuring lisa
and um
you